welcome to the program chronovirus
restrictions have been extended in
japan's capital just 77 days
before the scheduled start of the
olympic games a state of emergency was
due to end
in four days but cases are still surging
and there are fears about how prepared
tokyo will be
for the olympiad well let's cross over
to tokyo uh for the very latest with our
correspondent fadi salami uh fadi just
tell us more about the implications now
of the decision
so close to the olympic games
well this decision has been well
expected as we have been seen
as we have been seeing increasing
numbers of infections not only in tokyo
but also in osaka
it has seen one of the highest
infection numbers during the last few
weeks and
even though the government has issued a
state of emergency and it was should
and should be till the 11th of this
month but
the numbers of infections they didn't go
down
the government was hoping that the
so-called golden week it's a set of
holidays
where people enjoy like this long
holiday in japan and
the government was hoping that people
would stay at their homes and
that this will help to reduce the number
of infections but
actually the opposite has happened many
people haven't been
i haven't been replying to the
government's calls to stay at home and
we have seen
huge numbers of people like going out
for picnics going out for holidays
and even in train stations it has been
reported that
the number of people in shibuya station
one of the busiest stations in
tokyo has seen about three hundred
percent
uh increase comparing with the states of
the numbers at the state of emergency
last year so
very clearly that people were not uh
taking
enough precautions during this period
and it seems that the government has
realized that
with this situation going on maybe uh
more and more
uh the situation will uh will be
worse more and more and this is why they
have decided to extend
the state of emergency till the last
until the end of the month okay fatty i
mean how will this impact now on the
debate around
uh the olympic games to go ahead because
there is divided opinion
and it's been divided for quite some
time
well it of course it has increased the
debates about
the possibility of holding the games and
certainly it has weakened the prime
minister's position
on being very keen to hold
the olympics on date he has promised to
hold the olympics in a safe and secure
way
and very clearly that uh two and a half
months
uh to the games that the situation is
deteriorating the creating and
it's not uh at uh uh under control the
also the
prime minister has promised to uh for
the olympics to be a declaration of the
humanity overcoming the pandemic but
also
again this is very clear that that's not
the situation and in one hour we're
going to
see him talking in about the details
about the new extension of state of
emergency
in a press conference at the prime
minister's residence
fadi salemme our correspondent there in
tokyo thanks very much